family
dik host muta ya da kısaca di oma da
diyebilirsiniz.
Almancada babaanne ya da anneanne
kelimeleri yoktur. O yüzden genel olarak
büyükanne ifadesi kullanılır.
Gross mut
gros fata ya da kısaca opa
grtan. Büyük ebeveynler bu kelime
Türkçede bulunmaz.
Di muta hitap ederken mama ya da muti
diyebilirsiniz.
Muta
de fata
samimi bir şekilde papa ya da fati
diyebilirsiniz.
E fr ya da fr bu ifadeleri eş olarak
kadının eş olması durumunda
kullanılabilinir.
The man ya da man
eltan bu çoğul bir ifadedir. Tekil hali
bulunmaz.
Tochter,
der sonvesta
Almancada abla kelimesi yoktur. Onun
yerine grfesta kullanabilirsiniz.
Dea
abi kelimesi de yok. O yüzden de gros
bruda diyebilirsiniz. Ya da küçük
kardeşinizi tarif etmek için decline
bruda diyebilirsiniz.
Digfista
aynı Türkçedeki gibi digşista çoğul bir
kelimedir.
The ankle
the anklin.
The tent
Almancada teyze, hala, yenge için tek
bir ifade kullanılır. The tente.
The uncle. Yine hem amca hem dayı hem
enişte için theil
başka bir ifade yok.
Der nee
die nicht
der cousine.
Kinder,
das baby,
die baby
şahıslar ve artikellere bir bakalım.
Almancada hatırlayalım. Dea, das
şeklinde artikeller vardı. Ve şahıslarda
bunların kullanımı basittir. Çünkü
mantığı vardır. Örneğin bütün dişi
varlıkların artikeli di olur. Yine çoğul
olan varlıklar mesela kuzenler, çocuklar
gibi. O zaman da bunun artikeli her
zaman için d olur. D artikeli. Bütün
erkek varlıkların artikeli the olur.
Baba, dede gibi, amca gibi. ise çocuk,
bebek ve kız çocuk ifadelerinin artikeli
does yani nötr olur. Benim annem, benim
babam derken mine ya da mine kelimesini
kullanmamız lazım. Mine'ı ne zaman
kullanmalıyım?
There ya da does artiklerine sahip. Yani
sahip olduğum benim dediğim şey erkekse
ya da nötrse o zaman mine demeliyim. Ya
da dişiyse ya da çoğulsa o zaman da mine
demem lazım.
Mine fata is muta ya da doesn't m kinda
ifadelerinde olduğu gibi. Şimdi aynen o
örneklerle devam edelim. Bu benim yani
bu benim annem, bu benim babam şeklinde
tarifte bulunalım. Ne demiştik? Mine ya
da mine'ı kullanmamız lazım. Do ist bu
bir kalıptır. Bu şekilde kullanılmalı.
is mine. Erkek ya da çocuk için ya da
dişi için.
Mine bu şekilde kullanmalıyız. Örneğin
is mata
is tante.
Das ist onkel.
Nöür bir varlık.
Baby.
Bunlar benim. Yani çoğulda ne yapmamız
lazım? Çoğulda da z fiilinin çoğul
halini kullanmamız lazım. Yani is yerine
zint kullanmalıyız. Ve mine mı m'ı mı?
Ne demiştik? Çoğulda da mine kullanmak
zorundayız. Doesn't mine
doesn't mı Eltan?
Do m gşvista. Buradaki Eltan ve gışta
kelimeleri zaten doğal olarak çoğul
kelimeler ama bazı kelimeler tekil
halleri de var. Örneğin teyze gibi.
Detent teyze. Detenton teyzeler. Çoğul
cümle kurarken mutlaka kelimenin çoğul
halini kullanmak zorundayız. Do m ten
bunlar benim teyzelerim.
Onun adı şimdi sahip olduğumuz ailemizi
tanıtıyoruz. Adını da söylememiz lazım.
Bunun için hen fiilini kullanabiliriz ya
da zine fiilini de kullanabiliriz. Örnek
verelim.
Oma yani o o'ya göre fiilimi çektim. My
oma heelope.
Adını en sona yazdım. Mest penelope ya
da zilini de kullanabilirsiniz.
O isten
lope. Ya da sürekli myoma demek
istemiyorsanız o da diyebilirsiniz.
Z heist ya da is penelope.
Erkek örneğine bakalım. My opa hest ape.
My opa is ape. Aynı şey sadece mine
yerine mine kullandık. A he yani o için
z değil a kullandık. E he ya da a
çoğul olursa nasıl olur? My grtan. Büyük
ebeveynlerim bu sefer çoğul halini
çekmem lazım.
GR
sind penelope
ya da de diyebilirsiniz o ifadesi için.
Penelope ap. Şimdi yaşını da söyleyelim.
Onun yaşı şu şeklinde. Burada yine zign
fiilini kullanmamız lazım. Yaşını
söylememiz lazım. Ve en sona da yağı alt
ifadesini yerleştirmemiz lazım. Örneğin
şesta o meşesta ist
ya da o istin
brud
alt
yapalım.
Bu şekilde de birleşik yazabilirsiniz.
Ya da onlar
benim bir annem var, benim bir kardeşim
var ifadelerinde var kelimesi için
haveen fiilini kullanmamız lazım. Şimdi
burada benim bir dediğim için bir de
kelimesini kullanmam lazım. Ama ve
kelimesini kullanırken işin içine biraz
gramer giriyor. Onu çok kısa anlatacağız
derine dalmadan. Eğer sahip olduğum
şeyin artikeli D olursa çocuk ya da
bebek gibi kullanıyorum. Ya da dişi bir
varlığa sahipsem anne gibi, teyze gibi,
nine gibi o zaman bir tane E harfini
ekliyorum. Aynı kullanıyorum. Eğer erkek
bir şeye sahipsem bir baba, bir amca
gibi o zaman aynen şeklinde önüne bu
kelimeyi koyuyorum. Örneklerle
anlaşılır. Örneğin habe örneğimizi
sürekli benim var şeklinde sürdürelim.
Annenin bir bebeği olsun. Yani does
baby. Gördüğünüz gibi does artikeline
sahip olduğu için hangi kelimeyi
kullanmamız lazım?
Baby benim bir bebeğim var. Ya da benim
bir kız kardeşim var. Yani artikeli di
olan bir kelime.
Ayne. İşhab aynı şfesta e harfini
arttırdım.
Ya da bir erkek birisine sahip olalım.
Erkek bir şahsa. Örneğin erkek kardeş
gibi. O zaman ne kullanmalıyız?
Aynenı.
Aynen h fiilini kullanırken buna dikkat
etmeyi unutmayın.
Ya da yok derseniz yani benim bir
kardeşim yok gibi ifadelerde nasıl
kullanabilirsiniz?
Çok basit. Bütün aynı az önceki kurallar
geçerli. Sadece ayn kelimesinin önüne k
harfi koymanız yeterli.
Kin baby. Benim bir bebeğim yok.
Benim kız kardeşim yok.
Benim erkek kardeşim yok diyebilirsiniz.
Çoğul olursa bu kurallarda biraz
değişiyor tabii ki. O zaman örneğin
çoğul olduğu zaman sayı
belirtebilirsiniz aynı yerine. Ya da
yine sıradan bir cümle kurarken artık
ayn kelimesini kullanmanız yasak. Ay
çünkü bir demek. Çoğulda bir kelimesi
olmaz. Örnek verelimaş.
Burada aynı kelimesi yok. Benim
kardeşlerim var.
Benim iki kardeşim var. Ya da yok dersek
benim kardeşlerim yok.
Yani teyzelerin çoğul hali. Teyzeler.
Bu tür cümlelerde her zaman için
kelimenin çoğul halini kullanmayı
unutmayın.
Ailemize tanıtmak için gerekli olan
bütün bilgileri artık öğrendik. Şimdi
sizinle bir tane örnek metin üzerinden
devam edelim.
Ben Maggie.
Ich bin ein alt
tolle familie.
Meine mutter ist Marin
Vater Homa.
Sie sind 369.
Ich habe zwei Geschwister
mein Bruder
Bart.
Er ist 10 Jahre alt. Meine Schwester
Lisa.
Burada yı alt ifadesini
bırakabilirsiniz.
Familie
deszens.
Aile kalbin vatanıdır.
PDF dosyası ekledim. İndirip
çalışabilirsiniz. Yine oyun linkleri
üzerinden alıştırma yapabilirsiniz. Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere. Hoşça
kalın.
Yeah.